Whoa, hey
Whoa
Heyyyyyyyy.
ThAt's a little early!
Don't you thi- AH FUCK
WHOA HEY!
THAT IS REALLY EARLY
WHY ARE YOU HERE?!?!
I was having a fun time oN MY OWN
RAAAAAAAUURH
RRRAAAAUUuror...
oh, okay, alright
I gotta go gotta go gotta go
gotta go gotta go gotta go gotta go go go
gooOOOOho
ee, get Long Legs Larry
get Long Legs Larry
and get Long Leg Larry outta here!!
Fuck Off!
Oh fuck I heard that door
I heaRD THAT DOOR
I heard that door
I heard it
Okay
So!
Hi!
Welcome back everybody!
I had to play through the game again because the game got updated
and, uh, they fixed a bug,
which I don't think I was subject to so
I was just
I was havin' a lot of fun! By myself!
Figuring out the Puzzle!
Which I already knew how to beat
So anyway
Welcome back to Mirror Layers, um
In this episode, we are going to be figuring out the mystery of the tape
which -
Hopefully -
if we come over here,
it won't just lead to our imminent demise
and, uh
I'm pretty sure I prolly
Yeah, I - I still got Father
so, I still had box 4
(tape playing) Aaand welcome boys and girls!
*static* Here live for the *static* and 12 minutes broadcast (tape end)
for the - what?
Twelve minutes?
Oh!
That's right!
So, here's the secret to this.
It gives me a letter,
and I'm going to write this down because I've got a notepad right here,
it gives me "D", and then it gives me a number
the 12 minutes podcast.
And I learned this all because there's that big facebook group.
Oh and also!
I - I'm back to my original hair color -
This is a bad place to be talking about this
So, if you look at the clocks,
there is... 12:45,
There's 3:00...
There's um
There's
two...thirty-three
an- oh hwuuh fuck hi
And then there's
There's uh... 4:12
So there's 4:12
2:33
4:12, 2:33, 3:00 and then 12:45
And then there's this.
"D".
So "D"... uh this is a lot to remem-
aaAAHH fuck it!!
HI FUCK YOU'RE OUT THERE QUICKLY
WHOOOAH HEY
HHHHHI
okay
So anyway
Hrrr fuck
So
Ah
Whhat the fuck was I trying to remember?
That's right
okay
So we got D - 12
Which relates to
12... 45
And then
we've got other letters
that come in other tapes
that go IN
to the statue input
which I've got
hhriiIIIIGHT here
Fuck.
I am hearing those stippy-steppy sounds everywhere I go.
SO. YEah
Bit of a rushed, entry into this game?
I don't know why every time I play this game
It's always like a frantic sprint to get to the done
I've gone to that page
and I've downloaded all of the tapes
these are every one of the tapes
uh
and I'm gonna put 'em into the statue input
And uh
Even though I've already got Father here
I bet I'm gonna get a duplicate copy of it
or maybe I won't I'm not sure
but um
Here they are!
Heh
Just like that, I g-
we got
Daaad
We've got FAther
We've got. Dad
Father again, so I did get a duplicate Father
Not that I needed it, I'll put it over in the
Father column
And then we got DAddyy
and then we've got
ffffffffffucker
we've got a tape labeled ffucker
*phone ding*
right, dere
stOP
dingin' me I'm not in the moood
okay, so
one thing I forgot to, also write is
um, the other times
it was 3:00,
4:12 and then
t-two
thirty-threeeee?
Thirty-two, thirty-three...
I can't remember specifically
Um
Now that I'm looking at this, I'm thinking, uh
I may-
I'm thinking this actually might be this time
So what I gotta do is I gotta take these tapes into the game
individually
and then look for the letter
and *shouts over static* LISTEN
for the time that they say
'cuz they will say a time
pop that bad boy in there
(tape playing) Hello everybody. Welcome to Classic Radio
*static*
Here for the *static* -o'clock broadcast
Did it say 3 o'clock? 3 o'clock
E! E is 3 o'clock
So I'm gonna take this tape back with me
Heh, heh, heh, heh, HEH
Lemme THRU
HEYAH
So that's good
*static*
Okay
So that was 3:00.
That was 3:00
So that's good
Put that there
So that means E...
E is 3
E
This is E
E is 3:00
Then I've got the Daddy tape
*static*
E is also Dad...
okay
put that in there
(tape playing) Hello everybody and welcome to Classic Radio
*static* here *static*
and we're at the *static* and 45 minutes broadcast! (tape end)
B - 45! B - 45, B- 45, B - 45
can I gO THROUGH
*static* Hi okay
That was a bit of a delay, I didn't like that!!!
Okay, B - 45
So B..
B is 12:45
Okay, so, and then...
fffUCker
*static* ffUcker
must be
the last one
which iiiiisss
(tape playing) Hello everybody! Welcome to Classic Radio and
*static* here for the *static*
(Mark) G!
(tape) and 33 minutes live broad- (tape end)
33. So G - 33
So I've got that, so now I've got
all the pieces - aaAAWW
ok *static*
that was fucking weird
it was like, blacked over
If I go over there too much, am I not gonna be able to return?
Aw, probably
Okay
So we've got...
D,
4:12
E, 3:00
B, 12:45
and G, 2:33
So because...
Because they were calling out the minutes
and, if I'm not mistaken -
hang on, let me get this where I can see it -
I can see it like right there
okay, so, right there - okay -
so if I'm not mistaken -
I'm risking something by going in here.
I've been going in here a lot, very quickly.
but over here, you've got
Okay, it goes up to 8.
So it can't be 12...
So it's gotta be either some summation of all the other numbers...
fuck
It- it- it's either a summation of the other numbers
or- aH Fuck
That's quick
OH that's really quick!
AAAUHHE
Ah...
Hi.
HI
How are you??
Lemme get a look atcha
I don't wanna get a look atcha
uuUEEH
UEEH
AAAH I DOn't like that
fucking hell
that's weird
oH What're you doin??
oOOOOOOH I don't like that...
OOOOOOOOH I don't like that!!!
oh fuck. where's he going
YEE
HI
HWOAHFUCK
REEH
Oh god, did he loose me??
Oh I think he lost me!
oh...
Maybe if I crawl...
All stealthy-like...
they'll never fi- (door creaks) aaUUH
they'll never find me...
they'll never find me.
oh boy. oh boy. oh boy.
He'll never find me!
So I have to get...
So I'm assuming it's D - 4,
E - 3,
B - 12, and then G - 2
is he gone?
*gasp* i think he's gone!
he's probably not gone.
okay, but either way!
I think, I thinky-think
I think
It's B... probably 3
D - 4,
E - 3,
then G - 2...
*error buzz*
nOPE that was Not It okay
So these are the definites,
It's definitely E - 3, definitely D - 4 -
Well maybe not.
No,
Cuz 45 adds up to 9, so that wouldn't be it.
So it's gotta be a B number.
So I'm just gonna start - ah fuck
G - 2... E - 3, D - 4,
(look out mark! the door!)
I mean there's only so many combinations to be-
fUCKING
FUCKING WHAT
hOLY FUCK
The FUCK!?!!
(screeching) The FUUUCK
(still screeching) The fuck was that!!!?!?
The fuck!??
He was SIIIiiIIIIlent
Man
I don't know why...
My voice has /not/ recovered yet.
My voice has absolutely not been able to recover...
No matter what I do.
Oh man, and I keep playing these horror games
that just thrashes it over and over again
Am I even back in the same -!? Ok, I am back in the same spot, at least.
Okay. So,
It was G - 2- ugh, I'm gonna die-
Maybe too many failed attempts is just death.
Don't like it-
... E - 3 ...
*error buzz*
Fucking, god damnit, not tha- NOT THAT
oh- FUCKING NOT THAT!!!
FUCK OOOFFF
Ooooohh
OOOKAY
ALRIGHT
OOOOOOOOH
AAAAAAAHHHH
Okay
Oh God, I hear him.
Oh hey, hullo
*whispering* what the fuck was that?
what is in here?
Oh it's- it's the arm.
OH
I'M GONNA CALL YOU ANGULAR ARM ANGELA
OH WE'RE GONNA GO ON AN ADVENTURE, ANGULAR ARM ANGELA!!
Oh, hi.
You're getting a little too close to my face, Angular Arm Angela.
oh, god
he's out there
and he doesn't like me very much!
He doesn't like me much at all
Hello! Hi
I gotcha somethin'... You're welcome. You're welcome
Oh, you're welcome. Okay. Alright.
WOOOO
WOOOOOOO
Oh, man.
So I'm unna find out what the next puzzle'll be-
be- because- I haven't looked into this.
*static*
So Idon't exactly know what- hello.
"F 7 7 F"
Okay...
That's good?
I don't know what that means.
Okay, so I, ooo hello
"21 U C"
Okay...
So we've got books with codes...
So that means there's gotta be...
Someplace to put in the codes.
Maye just back in the computer.
No books.  Books books books books... books. Books?
BOOKS
Gimme books
Anybody got some bay-ooks?
So this is the fir- oh hello
Ugh. I don't like that!
"8 f z k"
Alright.
So this is the first time that it's given me
more than one thing in my world.
Woah- Woah that's different
Woah tha- that's different. Okay.
Have I seen that? I don't think I've seen that.
Well I don't think I've been in this bath-*GASP*
fuUUUUUUUUUUUCK
fucking FUCK
Oh my god. I thi- I think what it is-
aaAAYAYA
I think what it is- he'll kill you if you spend too long in that world no matter what.
You can allude him, but he'll getcha.
Oh, he's gonna getcha.
He's gonna getcha good.
Okay, so, I can only assume that
I can only assume that
Those go in somewhere
So it was F77F, maybe if I put that in
F77F.
NOPE that ain't it.
Okay
Lemme see if there's more...
Cuz there's been 4 things in every one
I gotta imagine that there's 4 books.
So I got 3...
I'll write down all the codes in a bit
oh, here we go
"Q E B K"
Bad idea. This is a bad idea
21UC - oh this is a bad idea
21UC- oh this is a /bad/ idea
OH this is a bad idea
F77F
ok
Do they have numbers on the sides?
Oh boy- uh- okay
I- do they have numbers on the sides?
I can barely make ou-
aw fucking fuck
HEY
fuck i thought i heard something
Q, U- I-
I see something on the side.
But I can't tell what it is.
This definitely hasn't been there-
3 seconds...?
What does that mean?
HEY
fuck. fuck fUCK FUCK
HEY. Hey hey
Fuck. Hey
Fuck you- FUCK
FUCK. I'm- FUCK
Okay. So I'm gonna take this with me-
*static*
Okay so 8FZK...
Maybe if I put them through the statue
they're gonna tell me something.
So I'm gonna put this one through the statue
and see what it means.
So if I put this here...
aaAA boop
Okay "transfer to your world"...
I go to the- I go to the output folder
DEATH. Oh.
Death. Oh, good ol' Death
Okay so I'm gonna copy this
I'm gonna put this...
in the books!
I'm gonna create a books folder
I got death.mirrOR
which is GOOD
i THINK
*static*
So at least I'll have hard copies of all of these
oh god
I CAN'T GO BACK THROUGH
AAAH.
I WANNA GO BACK
Please let me go back...
Please...
Please let me go back
QEBK
Maybe- maybe I put them in in capital letters
*static*
QEBK...
So.. lemme try...
lowercase qebk.
q, e, b, k
♪♪♪♪♪
aaAAAAH
f, 7, 7, f
♪♪♪ ♪♪♪
HUUH
O- oh wait, is that morse code?
Hang on.
♪♪♪♪♪
*to the tune of the notes* Doo doo doo doo doot
Druid sandstorm?
♪♪♪♪♪
Doo doo duh duh duht
So maybe that last one's long
But I'm gonna assume qebk...
ok
So if I put this over here
qebk is
uh
it's... dot dot dot
long
♪♪♪ ♪♪
duh duh da da da
okay
so
is.. lemme- yeah lemme take out this first one
duh duh duh d-
this one was-
duh duh duh duh duh
ok what's this one?
♪♪♪♪♪
yeah that's five.
that's druid sandstorm
daht daht- dah dah dah
ok. duh duh dah dah daht
ok then we got-
21uc
♪♪♪♪♪
That was- that was five short
that was definitely five short
duh duh duh duh duht
and then the last one is-
oh wait no th- f77f was
duh duh dah dah daht
so q, f, z, k
*boop*
?
qfzk?
*boop*
That was it!!!!
That was the one!!! qfzk!!!!
EIGHT fzk,
8fzk, not q, 8.
So 8fzk
So, I didn't need to bring them over here,
It's saying book position...
So maybe I gotta, like, put 'em back...
So 8 fzk.
Not q, 8.
8.
8fzk.
♪ ♪♪♪♪
yeah
loong short short short short
Okay
So I got these coordinates,
so 8fzk that's the first one I'm gonna go for
duuh duh duh duh duht
okay then I'm gonna get this where I can see it again
oH NO
right there...
ok, so I'm going to take 8fzk
*static*
And so- I gotta- I gotta find
like, a bookshelf...
No...
eee.
There's a bookshelf over here...
No..?
Oh no.
Okay. Not there...
I don't see- oh! Hey!
Th- there's a chest.
o-OOOH
Oh. I gotcha! I gotcha
Oh I gotcha
oOokay
So...
shit. Uh...
duh duh dah dah dah... fuckin
I don't know what this means to this
ah, shit.
Ah, fuck
oKAY
ALRIGHT
AAHH
Where the FUCK are ya??
Where the FUCK are ya
eeh?
*static*
Okay
SO
What I've got
Is i've got a puzzle and I've got all the pieces
But what I don't have is time, so
Unfortunately,
I'm gonna figure this out in the next episode
But I've got everything that I need right here in front of me,
so I should be able to do this
easily.
I've got all the information,
I've got all the books,
I just need to put 'em on the bookshelf
and open the box.
so I'm going to get to that very quickly, so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
lemme know what you think down in the comments below
lemme know how far you've gotten,
and if you wanna go over to that facebook group
and you figured things out yourself,
help other people.
There are other people who are currently lost right now,
I'm not /lost/, but I
I'm gettin' there, so
either way, help 'em out,
lend a hand, and we'll get this mystery solved.
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you
IN the next video.
Buh- byeee!